apparently I've grown up but I still go
to places I've voice dreamt of as a
child I grew up on a farm so really no
other kids to play with so I ended up
just going into my imagination my world
is full of futuristic superheroes laser
beams spaceships and constructions
thought I've been inventor so became an
engineer but the imagination isn't
really encouraged when you're an
engineer luckily I found my own path I
try to maintain that sense of magic and
wonderful that we often lose as adults
I can actually be myself in this costume
I'm kind of expected to be unique than
usual suits me fine
[Music]
found this place to go to on a Monday
night
everyone goes crazy in the dark
I've actually shed some light on
something you don't normally see
she's bit naughty on me
welcome to no lights no Laker
[Applause]
so when the lights go out no one's
watching you you know you can get away
with whatever you want
feels like you are inside music video
feels like you've gone around you as an
amazing dancer super sexy no testicle II
cool when the lights come back on some
sort of transformation has happened I
don't know what they've been doing and
that you here and a part of it but I
love the way you can't see the
transformation the feeling I get when
I'm dancing in the day when you're free
and connected with your body and with
the community has basically been the
driving force behind my art
[Music]